as we prepare to get back to work let's
ponder the obstacles I count three so
far
first the media to capture their essence
completely let's roll this week's worst
question more Americans over the course
of six weeks and died in the entirety of
the Vietnam War does he deserves favor
election
so yeah we've lost a lot of people but
if you look at what original projections
were 2.2 million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many one person who's too many
for this great answer but an asinine
question does a leader deserve to be
re-elected after a tragedy strikes well
that's what the election is for you dope
the voters determine who deserves to be
reelected and you can apply this non
logic just about anywhere you know a
tornado killed the Johnson family on
Main Street the same a Main Street that
mr. Smith delivers the mail on shouldn't
mr. Smith resign from the United States
Postal Service see as long as the media
has no powers of self reflection they'll
never learn and keep making moronic
observations like this chap enough to go
to break there's a good thing about this
economic crisis
in the clean air and views we haven't
seen for a long time
[Music]
remarkable analysis death and economic
turmoil creates awesome visuals for our
carbon belching TV network
imagine Chucky how even better the
environment would be if the network's
also stopped working somehow I don't
think he thought that through
and finally how's this for a question
never to live from that I will never lie
to you you have my word on that
what kind of answer did this
grandstander expect clearly the question
was only asked to get headlines for
herself she's not just grandstanding
she's the whole damn stadium so what to
expect from this crew as we get back to
work more armchair quarterbacking
questioning the timing the phases the
risk and so on which is fine if there's
a problem they'll find it and pin it on
you-know-who not the Chinese of course
who needs Red China when you have orange
Godzilla so for the media and us humans
let's introduce gutfeld slaw which goes
like this if you contributed nothing at
the time of the event then you can't
point fingers in the future meaning if
you have no suggestions of when to go
back to work or when to shut down the
economy or when to shut down travel or
not and you have no evidence that you
ever said the contrary then take your
future analysis and shove it up your ass
if you had no skin in the game you have
no place at the table then there's the
next obstacle the politicians who of
course are gonna politic exploiting real
problems for their own political
survival every Democrat will blame Trump
for the pandemic Adam Schiff will lead
the way already announcing he'll be
helming a commission which is hilarious
given that his other quixotic
misadventure the impeachment proceedings
allowed the outbreak to take us by
surprise
you know I won't say Adam has blood on
his hands but if you were under water
he'd be mistaken for a lobster flatten
him and he'd make a terrific sunset and
then of course there's Hillary suddenly
appearing as Joe Biden implodes like a
drooling vulture eyeing a desiccated
hiker she pretended to be at his virtual
town hall to endorse Joe but real
it was an opportunity for her to knock
Trump who humiliated her in 2016 while
hoping obviously for a rematch but you
know I think Biden did a pretty good job
check it out hey there green shirt lady
I like green sike yellow and blue but
combined it's genius thank you so much
Joe it's a real pleasure to be here with
you I wish you were here in person green
shirt lady I've been binge-watching the
West Wing yeah hundred and fifty four
episodes straight and that is not only
disgraceful it is so outdated it is an
anachronistic hey take it easy green
shirt TV presidents are cool especially
Martin Sheen he's got that voice nice
head of hair maybe we ought to go with
him instead of me what'd he say think of
what it would mean if we had a real
president not just somebody who plays
one on TV all right how about movies
though you remember when Bill Pullman
saved us from all those aliens I better
be willing to do that again imagine the
difference that it make well I know what
a difference it would make because I've
been there I've seen firsthand what
presidents can and should do you know
what presidents can and should do
cocaine that'll get you going just
kidding lady stay in school kids don't
do drugs and thirdly there is the
disease itself going forward every
decision has a risk stay home
indefinitely people suffer go back to
work the disease could return we've
talked this thing out before we're smart
adults we can't be trusted I mean we
flattened the curve like pros not bad
for our first time ever it's a lesson
for all you undergrads taking courses on
American history where your feeble
bitter professors portray the country as
oppressive genocide all greedy it's all
bs this evil capitalist society in fact
just put its entire system in jeopardy
in order to save the sick the weak the
old you know even Sweden didn't do that
and aren't they the model for
progressive compassion I do love
they're fish now the president's
economic recovery task force released a
study predicting that a fast reopening
will end America's recession with a
quick recovery in the fall I know this
because I read it in their press release
I hope they're right I think we all kind
of feel like we're at a baseball game
and the 15th inning and we just want
this damn thing to end instead you don't
want to go home you want to leave home
and go to work you know which reminds me
I'm hoping a litigation shield will be
attached to these bailouts so companies
can get back to work without worrying
that they might get sued by a guy who
claims he got the corona from your bar
stool fact is you're not gonna restart
civilization if lawyers are in the room
imagine if they were present in other
world defining moments you think
Columbus would have discovered America
no way says a 15th century Ralph Nader
with those awful working conditions than
those ships you think Ben Franklin would
have enticed electricity with a kite no
where the where the hell's his permit
and his helmet although he looks like
he's wearing one and forget discovering
penicillin
it's a mold think of the allergies so
maybe let's be a little reasonable we're
all trying we're all on the same team so
while we all go back to work maybe you
lawyers take half days chill out catch a
movie because there's good news coming
we've got promising drugs flattened
curves newly adopted hygiene practices
and good people like you doing great
things that's the real weapon fact is
computer models weather for climate or
for disease never factor in human
ingenuity it can't because human
ingenuity is impossible to predict
except that you know it will be there
when the going gets rough and sure
enough it showed up because you did two
nice job